it's hard to believe it's been over
three whole months since those monsters
came to town if only I had known back
then what they were really doing here
maybe I could have stopped it I don't
know so much of this is beyond me what
could I have done even if I had known
about it could I have stopped what had
happened to all those people sickness
sarcasm the SCP Foundation it's all such
a blur but for a while I can still
remember how I spent 100 days
infiltrating a circuit cult it All Began
on a pretty ordinary day I live in a
small Lumber Town most the area is cut
off from major cities connected only by
Miles and Miles of Winding Road through
the forest it's a quiet rural place and
the low-tech way of life our main
business has been Timber generations of
tree cutters even in the Modern Age we
keep that going although my home has
always been off the Beaten Track we
often had our fair share of visitors
hikers and Wanderers who would sometimes
stumble upon the town quite by accident
yet be so enthralled by open Natural
Beauty on offer but they just have to
spend a night at the only hotel in town
the woodsman's lodge run by my friend
Andreas that's what we thought they were
at first just visitors that's why we
welcome them when they arrived because
not one of us had any idea who these
people really were what they really were
we could have never known that they had
chosen Our Town specifically they had
come here on purpose many of the wearer
among Our Town thought these newcomers
were strange there were a group of five
very obviously full of cash but less
obvious was the reasons for coming here
when friendly townsfolk tried to drum up
conversation with any of them they all
seem to report the same thing that these
strangers were aloof and each one gave a
dramatically different answer as to why
they had come to our quite little
locking Community one said their group
was just sightseeing another said they
had gotten lost someone else from their
group told a local man that they were
here on a mission from someone called
karcist varus and was rumored to have
been quickly silenced by another in the
visitor's party but the one thing they
all seemingly agreed on was that they
wouldn't be any trouble they insisted on
that in fact and said that the five of
them were just looking for somewhere to
sleep bed and bored in exchange for cash
and so someone pointed them in the
direction of andreas's Hotel I was often
there myself not as a guest but helping
my friend maintain the place he'd
inherited the hotel from his family but
it was always in need of repair luckily
my background was in carpentry and I was
more than happy to help Andreas out it
wasn't one of your fancy furnished
hotels you know the kind you find in the
big city all slick and sleek and owned
by a big chain it was homely a more bed
and breakfast type of place it was
anyway whenever I was working over at
the woodsmans I'd observed the strange
group of visitors from a distance they
didn't seem to me like average tourists
or sightseers to me they looked wealthy
very wealthy it wasn't hard to picture
any one of them as a politician or
businessman the way they dressed and
carried themselves made it pretty clear
they were people of influence of course
that begged the question what on Earth
were people like that doing in a town
like this I first got to speak with one
of them after a few days the five
newcomers were down a man and didn't
seem at all happy about that the
remaining four were grumpy looking
angered and agitated I wondered if maybe
their fifth compatriot had left in the
night but when I asked around town
apparently nobody had seen him unless
he's crazy and decided to hike through
the woods on his own in the middle of
the night one of my friends scoffed
after telling me that no one had even
heard any cars leaving the night before
I decided to ask one of the visitors
when he passed me in the hallway of the
woodsman's lodge trying to approach the
topic as tactly as I could sorry to see
you're down a man I told him he stopped
in his tracks like I just caught him
doing something he shouldn't be yes yes
he replied not turning around to face me
it is a terrible shame a terrible shame
indeed but he had to leave us it was for
his own good he knew that well following
that odd encounter things got all the
stranger the following day I arrived at
the woodsmans again expecting to start
another day of work I'd gotten a call
from Andreas earlier that morning he was
complaining about some kind of
squelching noise coming from the
basement under the hotel that had only
started last night I told him I wasn't a
plumber but that I'd take a look so
imagine my surprise when I saw Andreas
loading most of his worldly possessions
up into a truck outside of the front of
the hotel he excitedly explained to me
that he'd been bought out with the
remaining four newcomers had offered to
buy the woodsmans on the spot but that's
your family's Hotel Andreas I reminded
him as if it was already too late I was
never gonna keep it afloat forever he
Shrugged when they told me how much they
were willing to pay I couldn't refuse
would have done the same ingvar I've
never been offered so much money this
all made it very clear these guests were
here to stay it had taken less than a
week for me to grow suspicious of these
people it wasn't in my nature to pry but
so much about them just didn't make any
sense they were clearly Rich enough to
buy andreas's Hotel like it was nothing
just like an ordinary everyday purchase
like buying a loaf of Brad but they were
far too insular to seemingly want to run
a hotel for our friendly logging Town it
left me scratching my head over the
whole thing making the question of what
they were really up to stick out like an
unignorable Splinter were these just
careless Rich folk with more money than
sense had they somehow grown
disillusioned with their wealthy
affluent Lifestyles we're now using this
hotel to learn how to connect with
people on a more fulfilling personal
level or did they have a different
agenda something else that they were
trying to hide it turns out they did I
decided to formally introduce myself to
the new owners of the woodsmans after
all I knew this place well it always
needed something repaired plus if I
could keep my little side job of working
there as a handyman going then maybe I
could find out exactly what they were
doing I was greeted by the man I'd
spoken briefly to the other day looking
at me with the skull as I stood in the
doorway hello sir I greeted warmly met
with silence uh we uh we met the other
day what do you want oh well um I
continue disarmed by the bluntness I I
understand your group just bought this
place I had a gentleman's agreement with
the last owner I'd help him out fix
things that need fixing I just thought I
should offer the same service to you if
you'd be interested might help get this
hotel up and running nice and quick for
you so you can start making a return on
your investment with that the door was
unceremoniously slammed in my face at
first it certainly seemed like my
options for uncovering more about this
strange group were all but depleted or
at least doing so through any legitimate
means but just as I was reaching a
desperate point where I was considering
donning a balaclava and breaking into
the hotel in the dead of night
opportunity re-emerged from behind that
closed door we were sorry to turn you
away yesterday one of the other visitors
apologized someone insincerely but we
would be delighted to take you up on
your offer provided you accept a few
conditions conditions I echoed what
would those be we would need you to
start on repairs immediately we want to
open up the hotel's doors to guests in
the next few days as a matter of urgency
he explained but you will need to be
discreet privacy is very important to us
so we hope to maintain that for our
guests it all seemed like a lot of Hoops
to jump through certainly more than
Andreas had ever given me when he used
to run the woodsmans but it felt like
the right call if at least it got me
closer to answers in hindsight I should
have turned them down over the course of
the next week things seemed to run
relatively normally I'd be given a
checklist of things to fix around the
hotel and for the most part just focus
purely on the tasks at hand but whenever
the strange new owners were near I'd try
to subtly listen in on their
conversations they seem to mostly talk
about running the hotel though like they
knew I was around a few tourists started
showing up in fact it seemed to get much
busier than usual pretty quickly I asked
one of the odd owners about it and he
just brushed it off as the result of
their group's marketing the woodsman's
lodge more widely on the internet I
didn't see much of the hotel's guests
staying out of their way as I'd been
instructed to but it did strike me as
odd how few of them seem to leave some I
spotted around town usually those
traveling as a couple or in a larger
group any that were staying alone though
they didn't seem to venture beyond the
woodsmans none of them checked out
either but their rooms would be empty
and often needing repairs mainly scratch
marks on the wooden floorboards two and
a half weeks after that weird group had
arrived and bought up my friend's Hotel
I got a call from someone I knew who
lived next door to the woodsmans the
hotel someone was screaming she said
frantically over the line get her quick
they might need you I checked the time
it was the dead of night so late that it
was almost the start of the next day
racing quickly over to the hotel I was
greeted by one of the owners he had
rushed to the door wide awake like he
hadn't even been sleeping when I told
him there were reports of blood curdling
screams he reprimanded me you were told
our guests privacy must be maintained he
scolded if you must know one of the
hikers staying with us tripped over and
had a nasty fall he landed downstairs in
the basement and he's in a lot of pain
not to be moved we've already called for
an ambulance wanted to take what he said
at face value but the fact he wouldn't
let me see the injured man felt
suspicious I spent the night with the
person who lived next door to the hotel
watching the woodsman's launch for any
sign of ambulance it never arrived that
was when I remembered he had said the
guest fell into the basement the same
basement Andreas had heard a strange
squelching coming from and not once had
these new owners asked me to take a look
down there already I was even further
suspicious of the new owners now I had
no idea what they were up to the wild
theories in my head range from them
being a group of sadistic serial killers
using the hotel to lure victims for a
shadowy government Black Ops team up to
something nefarious enough was enough I
needed answers I couldn't wait for an
opportunity I had to create one while as
few people were in the hotel as possible
I snuck into the main office not to
steal anything or even Peak just yet or
break the legs off a desk if they asked
me to fix it then I'd be able to spend
longer in the office with no supervision
sure enough they soon asked me if I'd be
able to fix the desk and that was my way
in I started rummaging through the
filing cabinets rifling through whatever
I could find old expense reports legal
documents left behind by Andreas but
there was nothing that could give me any
inkling as to what was actually going on
until there was you see as much as it
came as a surprise to no one more than
me I wasn't the only one looking into
this new strange group one of the guests
entered the office and quickly realized
what he was doing at first he seemed to
imply that I was somehow in a league
with the new owners but I was able to
talk him around telling him I was just
trying to get to the bottom of what they
were up to that was when he revealed to
me who he was agent Clarkson he
introduced himself I'm here on behalf of
the SCP Foundation after he brought me
up to speed on what the hell all that
meant we arranged to reconvene somewhere
they wouldn't overhear us meeting up at
the lumber mill he explained that these
four strangers were a cult a subsect of
a strange religion I had never heard of
called sarcasism but after agent
clericsson described their practices I
wouldn't
forget ritualistic sacrifices
cannibalism and even far far worse than
that it made me feel sick just hearing
about it over the next few days
clericsson agreed to let me help in his
investigation offering me the chance to
help the foundation and make it so that
nobody in my remote little logging town
would ever have to suffer the memory of
what the sarcic cult were up to little
did I realize he also meant me I did my
best to spy on the death and disease
worshiping cultists without drawing too
much suspicion and reported my findings
back to the foundation agent but it
quickly became clear that he was
unimpressed with my current method of
just eavesdropping so instead he
suggested a more direct approach
clericson gave me a book on the sarkic
religion telling me to memorize as much
as I could and then approach the
cultists as if I shared in their Twisted
beliefs even reading the techniques of
grand karcissist ion was enough to make
my stomach turn all the grotesque things
that the founder of this cult's beliefs
preached in order to achieve something
akin to godhood it was horrific what was
much more horrific though was that our
plan went awry I asked to speak alone
with one of the cultists and instantly
started explaining that I have observed
them for a time and I come to realize
that we were one and the same in a state
of panic I regurgitated anything I could
still remember from reading about
sarcasism their goal to achieve
apotheosis through will the consumption
of gods and sacrifice but I must have
said something wrong one of them stuck
up behind me and knocked me unconscious
I woke up in a daze the splitting
headache running for my skull I was in a
cage in a part of the hotel I hadn't
seen before it was dark absent of
natural light there are others too I
recognized one or two of the hotel's
single guests also trapped in cages
agent Clarkson was nowhere to be found
the sarkic cultists spent the next day
asking me how I had found them I told
them the truth and answered their
questions the only way I knew how but I
couldn't make them believe me liar one
spat you did your homework I'll admit
but the foundation is known for working
in Broad Strokes missing out on the
finer details we're Neo sockets another
explained you were spouting the
teachings of the proto-sarkic religion
we believe the only way of becoming a
god achieving the apotheosis is through
sheer will and in terms of sacrifice one
of the other cultists chimed in will
sacrifice many in service of us few but
you'll soon come to witness more of that
they kept me in the cage for days
without food and barely any water I felt
so drained of energy before long and I
soon realized why no one had heard the
captive guests calling out for help they
were so weak that they could barely
gather enough strength to shout and
those that did their voices were too
weak to reach anyone above the basement
the cultists came and went all
throughout the day alternating between
running the woodsman's lodge and coming
down into the dark cramped and
disgusting room below the stench was
foul yet not one of the sarcic cultists
seemed to mine they would just talk
endlessly of about the new age of Flesh
before dragging their next victim out of
their cage at night and taking them into
a back room by this point all the
remaining Hotel guests that had been
caged up with me were gone I could never
fully see what went on in the other room
but I certainly heard a lot there were
muffled screams followed by chanting in
a language I didn't understand then came
the noise of something slithering all
the while the cultists who had gathered
in the room with their captive victim
kept reciting their incantations I had
no idea what was going on in there but
the hotel guests never re-emerged just
the sarkites I'd read enough about their
rituals to get a pretty good idea I'd
lost track of how long I'd been prisoner
when aging Clarkson appeared in the
basement the cultist spacks have been
turned just long enough for him to slip
downstairs undetected for a moment I
thought it was saved only for my heart
to sink when he told me he couldn't get
me out I pleaded with him but he
insisted that he needed to know exactly
what was going on down here as he left
me on my own I cursed
before much long the cultists decided it
was my turn they dragged me out of my
cage and into the back room strapping me
to a chair I had no strength to fight
back but I had plenty of fear there were
more cages back here it was an old store
room that they were now keeping
nightmares in the things in the cages
were disgusting Abominations masses of
bloody gooey flesh flesh that had once
been human I realized these were the
hotel guests the ones who traveled alone
who never checked out whose fingernails
had left scratches on the floorboards as
they were dragged out of the rooms by
the cultists using a cattle prod one of
the sarkides started directing a
creature towards me the horrible mutant
was getting closer an appendage
resembling an arm reaching out at me it
was going to turn me into one of them
and I couldn't stop it scared for my
life I mustered the little energy I had
left to try and pull away from the
sickening creature but just as it was
about to make contact someone kicked
down the door agent clericsen had
returned with reinforcements members of
a mobile task force that promptly
arrested the sarkic cultists and sealed
the room containing the monsters for the
time being he sat down next to me and
explained what had gone on but I was
barely awake enough to keep up with all
the details something about
scp-610 instances and rare to see them
this far out of Siberia but he promised
that the SCP Foundation would be
ordering the creatures to be incinerated
soon the woodsman's lodge would have to
be burned down as part of the cover
story as for me I just want to forget
the whole ordeal the sarkic cult all the
people they turned into monsters the
horrifying things they do the scp-610s
all of it I want it all gone luckily
agent Clarkson has given me something he
says will help with that he called it an
amnestic want an anomaly of your own
check out scpswag.com for high quality
SCP merch now go check out what does
this secret SCP religion believe in and
I survived 100 days hiding from the SCP
Foundation here's what happened for more
mysterious SCP offerings